hey everybody my name is bradley knapp
and
we've come together today to talk about
what is a dedicated host
dedicated host is a construct that you
see a lot in the world of cloud
but it's a little confusing what does
this dedicated host thing
actually mean why does it look like it's
so expensive when you compare it to
buying a dedicated
instance or just a normal virtual server
and the answer is
dedicated hosts are a way to provide
single tenancy
single tenancy means that no one else
can run on the compute
that you are running on so if we think
about a physical cloud host
right we've got our actual cloud server
here
this is the actual host that runs in the
data center
in a normal multi-tenant environment we
would take and we would divide that host
up into pieces
and every one of these pieces is a
virtual server that you would buy
right i'll just mark that as vsi in a
dedicated host
we still have the same host that same
box that we were talking about
before but instead this is your box
and you control all of the vsis that
schedule on to it
so instead of this being customer a and
this being customer b and this being
customer c
this is all yours and so you can choose
to divide it up however you want
you can have one third of it go into one
vsi and two thirds go into another
you can divide it half and half or you
can put lots of little bitty ones on it
and so the question of course always
becomes why would i do this
what is the value of a dedicated host
why would i purchase this thing
and the answer is really twofold first
is that single tendency that i mentioned
before single tendency means that you
don't have to worry about anybody else
being able to crash through the
hypervisor layer within this host and
get to your data
even though it's already incredibly
secured in the world of cloud
it's just one more layer of protection
this is very important for healthcare
workloads
folks in banking and finance like that
but in addition to that single tenancy
it also allows you to schedule workloads
that want to be close to be
each other close to each other so if we
think our of our example here where
we've got two vsis of the same size
let's imagine a high performance compute
workload something that in the world of
hpc
where you have lots of compute working
on the same problem
in order to minimize latency and
maximize performance
you want to pack these onto as few
physical hosts as possible
because data transit through a physical
host is much faster than data that goes
across the network
if we think about our example over here
where we've got our multi-tenancy
and we've got multiple multi-tenant
boxes
every one of these has to link together
and that link together takes time there
is a latency penalty that you pay
but in a dedicated host like we have
over on this side
because these all run on the same
physical box
you don't incur that latency penalty and
you can order multiple dedicated hosts
in order to make that happen
thank you so much for your time today if
you have any questions please drop us a
line below
if you want to see more videos like this
in the future please do like and
subscribe and let us know
and don't forget you can grow your
skills and earn a badge with ibm cloud
labs which are free browser-based
interactive kubernetes labs that you can
find more information on by looking
below
thanks again